ですから やっぱり問題です
すぐ決める能力とかね
そういうのはやっぱり貪瞋痴だけだったら出てこないということを言いたがってるだけなんですね
僕は ですから このいつでも混乱状態で
問題が起きても混乱状態で
だから怒りを生きがいにしてやる
欲を生きがいにしてやる
あるいは夢中を生きがいにしてやる
それは子供生まれた瞬間からもうずっとそれだけです
だからもうどうしようもない状態になってるんですね
人が意見出しても あんた変ですよとか
そんなこと言うなと みんなに嫌われるよとか
だから何ですかと バカに嫌われたって別に何のこともないんだから
それは日本の常識とは外れてるんだと
別に 別にどうです 何でしょうかね
それは バカな常識から外れたって
それこそいいんだから
そういう勇気がない そういうのはしっかりした明晰な知恵から生まれてくるものなんです
そういうことだから この身所っていうのは育てるとずっともう一体になる
自分の心で もう他のことはわからない
例えばお医者さんが医学のことはよく知ってるんだけど
農業のことは知らない
それで医学の話になっちゃうと
すぐ機嫌が良くなって乗ってくる
農業の話になっちゃうと
もうあくびを出して眠ってしまうということですから
それ自分慣れてる世界ではもう行動できるんですね
ですから 貪瞋痴の感情で育てられちゃうと
他の世界は知らない ですから
このアビダンマから注意して言えるのは
悪い感情ができるだけ生まれないように気をつけないと
もう大変なことになるということなんです
悪い感情があることは悪いということではないんです
それは人間には貪瞋痴も不貪不瞋不痴もあるのは普通であって
その中でやっぱりしっかりと不貪不瞋不痴の感情を育てるように努力しなくちゃいけない
それだけのこと そうすると貪瞋痴があっても弱くなって
もう誰にも害はない 自分にも害はない
ほどほどのところで止まるんです
ティーニミッダの場合はこのなんですね
コンチンスイミン それはどんな心で生まれるかというと
このササンカーリカ心が 6つあります
ササンカーリカって何でしたっけ
有業 ササンカーリカというんだけど
ササンカーリカ心がこの貪瞋痴には 4つと
それからえーと 瞋恨心じゃなくて痴根心
痴根心 2つですね その 6つもササンカーリカなんです
有業というんですね テキストでは有業と書いてあるんです
有業というのは この自発的にエネルギーを持って生まれる心じゃないという意味なんですね
[声] 怒りなし あったっけ
[声] そうそう そうするとそちら 1つありますね
痴根心両方有業か無業かどっちかかな
それはっきりしてないんです
とにかくササンカーリカ5つで取ってるんです
で 瞋恨心は有業で取ってるんです
痴根心は この有業無業の差っていうのは
もうなんでそんな差がしたかっていうことははっきりしないんです
身所の場合も そこら辺でほんのちょっと差があるだけで
他のところでそんな差がないんです
だからこの有業無業の差は
単なるこの不善心生じのためにできている差で
力があるかないかぐらいの差なんです
善心の場合はあんまり働きがない
そういうのは説明飽きましたから
昔 で それでこの あ また一つ残っちゃったっけ
ヴィチギッチャ ヴィチギッチャでまた一つ身所が残ってます
ヴィチギッチャ  [声]疑っちゃうっていうのは疑いですね
それはこの痴根心の疑
疑想の心に生まれるんですね
疑ってなお疑い その疑問はあの
あの普通我々はこの知識に基づいて疑うこととは違うんです
知識に基づいて あ これはこうだから
これはこうだから やっぱりこれはちょっとわかりませんとというのは疑いじゃなくて
それは知識なんですね
それと関係ないんですね
こちらの疑っていうのは
やっぱりもう判断能力は全くない状態で
心がすごい硬い状態なんですね
どっちにしようかとわからない状態
それは理解するためには
よく理解する方法っていうのは
自分の行動は完全にストップしちゃうんですね
疑いが入っちゃったら
例えば怒りが入ったら結構行動するんです
怒りが入ったりとか 人を叱ったり殴ったり
もう何とかするかもしれませんだけど
それは悪いかもしれませんだけど
行動的であることは確かなんですね
欲が生まれたらまた行動するんですね
疑いが入っちゃったら
もう完全に凍っちゃうんです
自分が何もできなくて
ですから この自分が人間として自分の行動的な場合は疑がない
行動がなくなっちゃって
なんとなく止まった状態になったら
もう疑が働いているんです
ですから どうしようかわからない状態で
判断できない状態もなんか似てはいるんだけど
まあこれもいいし これもいいしというと
どうしようかなというところも
やっぱりまあ まあその時でも行動はストップしちゃいますけどね
行動は止まる とにかく無知を理解する場合は
そういう場合なんですよ
心が止まっちゃうような状態
瞑想している時は結構無知の心は理解できるっていうのはそういうところなんですね
例えばいろんな妄想が生まれたりしたっても
その時は妄想はもう怒りか貪りの方の妄想ばっかりなんですけどね
まあそれはまあそれなりに妄想やとね
確認していけばいいし
心が働いてるんですよ
そこでどんどんなんかこの妄想なんです
確認もできないし なんか行動止まってしまう
しっかりと瞑想中ではこの確認することさえ
なんとなく疎かになったりする場合
その状態は無知の心なんですね
それを続けたら必ずしも眠気が出てくるし
ですから この 瞑想して自分の心を見ると
あ これは無知な心だということはきちんとラベリングを張ることはできるんです
その場合はね ラベリング貼らなくたってもいいんじゃないかとかね
それは面倒くさい 非常に面倒くさいとかね
ただ見ているだけでいいんではないかとか
偉そうなことを僕に言うんじゃなくて
それはもちろんとラベリングした方がいいんで
そういうことを言うと
私にどんどん怒られるだけで嫌われるだけで
それは私は楽しみにしているんです
とことんやってください
嫌われるようにさらにするんだ
じゃあビチビチはビチビチは心に生まれる
それで不善心所があります
それから善心所の組み合わせ
で あの相応部サーヴァダハラナっていうのなんでしたっけ
強情心所ですかね 強情心所って
清らかな心 心所は全部二五ありますね
その二五の中で一九は強情心所なんですね
どんな清らかな心にも
どんな素晴らしい心にも
心所は一九が生まれるんですね
その一九の分け方もあんまり面倒くさい分け方なんですけど
たくさんありますね で
まあサッバーサチ リストを見てください
チャート見たってもわかると思いますけど
サッバーサチ・ヒリ・オッタッパ・アローバ・ドーサ・タットラ・マッジャッタタ・カーイ・パッササティ・チッタ・パッサティとか長いリストなんですね
で そのリストは長いんだけど
そこで私はずっと何回も何回も言い続けたのは
この清らかな心っていうのはものすごく明るくて柔軟性があって元気なんですね
だから我々の心はすごく元気で明るくて柔軟性があるということはわかると思います
そのテキストでは何ページでしたっけ
四九ページにこの一九が出てくるんですね
で リストチャート六八
六九ページのチャート見ても
この強善浄心所というところを書いてます
そこで一九も書いてます
強善浄心所と だから説明はそれなりにそれなりにしましたからね
その一九種類の心所っていうのは
心がすごく明るくて 元気で行動的で
柔軟性があって 物事をいくらか理解できて
頑張っている だからストレスは全くない状態なんですね
そういう素晴らしい状態なんです
だからわざわざいいことをする時だけ
修行する時だけ善心所生まれるっていうことじゃないんです
二四時間の中で人間にはまあもうすごい元気な時もあります
それは欲で元気になっちゃうとストレス溜まる
怒りで元気になっちゃうとストレス溜まる
どこかでもうこれ以上ダメだということは出てくる
でも 不善心所の場合はこれでダメ
これこれ以上はダメということは生まれてこないんですね
すごい元気な状態なんですね
ですから そういう心を発見して
それを育てれば 人間にはいつでも善心で生活することができる
いつでもすごい明るく満ち溢れて
元気で満ち溢れて 幸福に満ち溢れて生きることができるんですね
なかなか人間というのは
まあ高慢やら嫉妬やら競争心やらもうそういう意固やらね
そういうものばっかりはよく知ってるんですね
だからすごくこの何て言いますか
このかわいそうっていうのかわいそうなんですね
ヴィパッサナーしなくたっても
どんな人間でも自分の驕慢
高慢 怒り 嫉妬 競争心 そういうのはわかっている
他のことをもう知ったこともない
ですから明るくなりたいんだけど
どうなればどうやれば明るくなるかはわからないんです
元気になりたいんだけど
どうすればなれるかわからない
教えてあげても全然聞いてくれないし
すぐまた元に戻っちゃうし
で まああまりお釈迦様の仏教は人気もないし
ですからこのいくら言っても違うんだから
それはしょうがないんだけど
私は諦めてるんだから理解するっていうことはまあおそらくないだろうと
で まあ例えばこの まあもうヒンドゥー教から見てもそこら辺理解しやすいと思いますよ
あの なんとかあの あの
と と あれ 何と何字と読むんですか？この歌のテキストは
マハーバーラタありますね
あの マハーバーラタの一部ありますね
バガヴァッドギーターという
マハーバーラタの中はね
章ワンチャプターですけどね
チャプターの一部ですけどね
その そのマハーバーラタのインド人の歴史物語なんですね
日本の歴史みたいな このアマテラスオホミカミのかなんとか何とかとか
こういうストーリーいっぱい入っている古事記みたいな
もうものすごい分厚い本マハーバーラタ
その中にチャプターあって
その中にまた一部がこのバガヴァッドギーターというテキストなんです
それは今ヒンドゥー教の聖典になっているんです
で ヒンドゥー教 伝統的なヒンドゥー教
バラモン教の聖典というのはヴェーダがあって
ブラフマナというテキストがあって
アーラニャカというテキストがあってウパニシャッドなんですけど
それでまるっきり関係なく
この古事記から取っていたこの歌の本を今聖典だと
で 思って そこでマハーバーラタ自体のあのくだらない物語は全部正しいんだと
また今信じていますけどね
それはそれでいいんだけど
そこでこのアルジュナという人がこの戦争の時にこの戦争をやりたくない王様を励ますんですね
行って戦えと この行って戦えという励ましいことが今聖典になっているんですけどね
それこそ素晴らしい人類の遺産
文化だとかね まあ仏教はそれを片っ端から否定するんだからどうもないんだけどね
なんであんなこと人類の遺産と言うんですかと
ただ道徳は否定してるんだからね
行って戦えと でもそちらに行っているのはこの
この人間にわかりやすいとはわかりやすいんです
このあなたにエゴがあるんだから
あなたは行動していないんだと
ストップになっちゃったんだと
だから戦闘に行ったところで
その人はなんで戦わなくちゃいけないかと
なんで私は私のおじいちゃんたちを殺さなくちゃいけないかと
と思って行動はストップになる
そうすると その人は戦争をしないで国を相手方に渡して帰っても
後で後悔する可能性もあるし
で 戦争して勝っても自分の親戚を殺しちゃって
義理の兄弟たちを殺して
何が面白いかと ただただ国のためにとかね
王になるために ということもあるかもしれませんし
そこでこのアルジュナがもう教えちゃうんですね
あんたエゴだと それは
あなたがいて叔父を殺すと思ってるんだか思ってるかと
そうじゃないんだと このカルマヨーガですよと
カルマっていうのは行為で
ヨーガっていうのはヨーガなんですね
行為自体はヨーガですよと
瞑想でしょう 修行ですよと
そこでどうやってカルマヨーガになるかで
そこにあなたがいるわけでもないし
そこに叔父さんたちがいるわけでもないんだと
それはもう神に決められた設定していることであって
あなたはその仕事をさえやればいいんじゃないかと
いちいちくだらないことを考えないで
今やるべきことだけやれと
それでどんな結果になるかっていうのは
あなたに知ったことじゃないんだと
それはもう神の事だと
ですから まあ自分が自分に
今の瞬間に自分に出てきた仕事だけする
私がこの仕事をすると言う気持ちさえ捨てると
それでもう心がまた行動的になって戦争するんですけどね
で まあそちらにこの分析しちゃうと
このいろんなことで悩んで
ああだこうだとかね 悩んだり困ったりして
行動はしない人を その悩み苦しみに置いといて
余計ないろんな考え方を置いといて
自害意識を置いといて
結果は気にするなと それは自分の責任範囲ではないんだと
自分の責任とは全く関係ない
自分が非創造物だから
そのある 何て言いますか
設計図があって その中に決められている歯車だから
それだけしてもらえばいいんですよと
神のために だから自分に決められた与えられた仕事をすることは
もう神に対する自分の責任を果たすことであって
それはどうなるかというのは
もう自分でもう別に考える必要はないと
そういうことという場合も
まあ見えるのはこの このどうすれば人間が元気で行動するかというメッセージもそこにあるんですね
その明るい いわゆる行動的な心の作る一つの手段
技なんですね ものすごい悪い手段ですけど
だからまあ手段はちゃんとした手段でないと
真理に智慧に基せた手段でないと仏教は認めない
あれは単なる暗示であって
大嘘であって 神がいるかいないかもわからないし
そのシステム正しいかないかわからないし
シャトリヤ族に生まれたんだからって戦争しなくちゃいけないってこと
誰が決めたんですかと
だからやっぱり革命的な人間が
やっぱりそのカースト制度を破って
ジャイナ教と仏教だけなんですけどね
カースト制度を破って
ジャイナ教祖様もシャトリヤカーストの人で
お釈迦様もシャトリヤカーストの人
よりOKなんですね お釈迦様は正真正銘の王子様でしたし
ジャイナはいくらかジャイナ教祖様はそういう血戚の流れがあったんだけど
シャトリヤ族であったことは確かなんです
バラモンではなかったんですね
でもその二人とも政治やらそういうことは嫌いでしたし
戦争のね 軍人になって司令官になって
じゃあ戦え 頑張れとかね
やつけろとかね そんなくだらないことやりたくないんだと
もっと精神的なこと もっと哲学的なことをやりたいと
だからやっぱり人間というのはそれぞれ自分がやりたがることがあるんだから
それをやってもいいんじゃないかと
それは社会システムから決めてくれるようなものに大きな迷惑なんですね
その社会システム自体が神に決められたということは
それは大嘘であって それをさらに進んじゃったら
やっぱりそれぞれ個が自分でやりたがることは
もしかすると神が決めたことかもしれませんし
ですから そういう立場から見た
例えば神を肯定して見ても
あの手段は間違ってるんですね
例えばシャトリヤカーストに生まれた人が政治はやりたくない
その代わりに農具をやりたがってるんだと
農具やっちゃうとすごい気持ちいいんだと
また能力もあるというならば
それも神が作ったものではないかと
それだったらその人 それやればいいし
ですからその手段は仏教では認めませんだけど
あの あの 何て言いますか
別にお釈迦様そんなお釈迦様そんな知らないんで
そんなもの そういうことあったこと自体もね
それは後で書いたもの
そのテキストはお釈迦様時代なかったんで
それがマハーバーラタの一部は出来ていたんです
物語の部分が このバーガヴァッドギーターっていうのは
お釈迦様の後 ずいぶん後で付け加えた部分
まあかなりどんどんどんどんじわじわと
少し加えて 少し加えて大きくなったで
そうでしたからね 一人書いたものじゃないんです
王政の詩人たちが まあ全部バラモン人ですけどね
書いたものですけど ですから
お釈迦様はあれは読むなと言ってるんですね
全くくだらないし ただの時間の無駄ですよと
マハーバーラタとラーマーヤナという二つは読むなと
だからといってお釈迦様文学反対ってそうではないんです
文学に反対ないで お経自体もすごい詩だから
このスッタニパータなんかの抜群の詩なんですよ
お釈迦様が言うのは くだらない詩をね
一万個作ったっても何の意味もないんだと
きちんと意味がある一行だけで
一つの歌だけで十分だよ
人間の心は変わって素晴らしくなってくるならば
ですから そういう歌だけだったらということでね
だからお釈迦様も結構詩を書いたんではなくて
作ったんですからね ですから文学反対わけではなかったんです
ただ 現代の歌みたいに
もう何の意味があるかと
わけのわからない英語の単語出るわ
英語の一部なければ歌じゃないんですね
あれほどひどくない なんて面白いですかね
日本語の歌だから日本語だけでなんで書けないんですかね
じゃあその歌ってる連中
英語を知ってるんですかね
それも知らない で またいろいろ辞書を引いたりして
またいろいろ研究しなきゃ
使ってる言葉の意味もわからないと
どこから何か見つかったら
それ何かに入れてと 強引に
それは歌でもなんでもない
ただの驚きだけで人の金を盗んで膨大な金持ってるだけ
歌だったら人の役に立たなきゃね
人間それを若者が子供たちに覚えておいて
たまに鼻歌でも歌ったりして
ああ 美しい文句やと そう言ったら
私は小さい時覚えていた一つの二行ぐらいの文句があります
それも一つのドラマなんですけど
このもうドラマ ずっと歌でやってるドラマで
この大学の文学のすごい王様みたいなこの教授が書いたドラマで
で 伝統的なストーリーでしたけど
そこで一つ この国のストーリーでしたからね
あの息子を 息子が父親を殺しに行っちゃうんです
で で 父親 それはこの父親はライオンなんですね
ライオンで出てきて で
ライオンの何て言いますか
あれ 動物 動物の中に家族を大事に守っている
それは若いの父親の長だからね
ライオンみたいな感じで
もういわゆるもう亭主関白というか
もうみんなの面倒見てあげる
で みんなもうライオンだからもう怖くて言わなくちゃいけない
でも息子が息子と娘がいて
息子が大きくなってくると
やっぱりこれ破らなくちゃいけないんですね
この動物を 破って出て行かなくちゃいけない
そこでそれぞれの人の心の問題
[背景の騒音]母親がやっぱり自分の息子だから
もう一人前になって この壁を破って出て行ってほしいし
出て行くのはそれはわかるし
だからといって息子が誰に反対するかというと
自分の夫に反対するんだから
自分がお子さんだから
やっぱり夫の肩を持たなくちゃいけないし
そこで悩みが出てくる
娘にしたっても もう優しい人だから
やっぱり父親のことすごく愛情を持って考えたりするし
息子がなかなか色恋がようなこと
とにかくしょうがない
それでお母さんが逃げちゃうんですね
子供と一緒に その場合
母親だから やっぱりとにかく子供のために何かしなくちゃいけない
そこで子供のことを決めて逃げると
父親は子供を探してくるんです
探してると それで暴れ回って
ライオンだからもうみんなにすごいもう損与えたりする
それで息子がもうじゃあライオン殺すと出ていくと
誰にも倒すことできない
倒すことできるのは息子だけなんで
これでは そこでこのお互いの心の状態をね
歌っていて 二行だけ覚えてるんで
そこでその行で言っているのは
この子に対する愛情がね
父しか知らないんだと
子は知らないんだよ その愛情が骨に入って
骨髄に入って いかに自分を痛めているかということは
まあ子供は知らないだろうという歌なんです
すっごい感動的に歌ってる
それもバックグラウンドで
バックグラウンドでこの合唱団が歌っていて
そこで父と息子が出会うんですね
出会って殺すんだけど
ですから このその二行でも
やっぱり何か世の中の真理を語ってるんですね
だからずっとその真実だから
子供のために両親というのはどれほど悩んでいるかって
子供はまるっきり知らない
その間 自分のことしか考えてない
で 戦ったり もうぶつかったり
家を出てもう全部壊したりする
それはまた父親は死ぬんだから
それもその死っていうことは
やっぱりこの象徴的なことだから
やっぱり子供のために死んであげるんです
ですから そういう そういうのは歌になるべき
世の中の人間の永遠の真理なんですね
今なんですかって 今って永遠に残る歌あるんですか？演歌にしたってあれほどクズなんだ
船の話とか酒場の話 よく歌うんですね
あの まああの 僕は手段のことを余計なところまで言ってしまったんだけど
やっぱり手段はなければ人は成長しません
だけど だからといって悪い手段を使ってはいけないし
手段自体も正しい手段でなければいけません
で 清らかな心 行動的な心を作る場合はわかりやすいということで
僕はこのバゴアギターのことを言いましたけどね
で バゴアギターで言ってるこのエゴを捨てろというところ
エゴを捨てて行動すると
そこら辺はまあ我々が賛成できるんですね
私がこれやってるんだと思って行動すると
どこかで疲れが溜まっちゃうんです
私を肯定したいんだから
私がこの仕事をやってるんだから
褒めてもらわなくちゃ腹が立つし
うまくいかなかったら腹が立っちゃうし
批判されたらまた怒ってしまっちゃうし
じゃあなくてエゴを捨てて
じゃあまあとりあえずこれはやらなくちゃいけない
ですからやりますと そういうことをすると
その行動からは充実感が生まれてくる
で どんな仕事でもできるんですね
みんなこの仕事を選んで走り回るでしょうね
あの仕事は嫌だ 他の面白い仕事ないんだ
そこに行ったらまたその仕事嫌だ
まあ他のそういうのはエゴで自分の好みに合ってる仕事を探している
自分の好みに合ってる何か行動を探して回しても
それは欲ですから 全然見つかりっこはないんです
エゴさえ捨てて まあ私がという言葉を使わなくちゃいけないんだからね
私が今何をすればいいかと
今これしかないと 選択はない
今これは作るんだ 今はこれはするんだ
それからこれするんだっていうことだけだったら
いつでも心は行動的なんです
一瞬したたまらない そこは精神症の働きをつかまる方法なんです
それはいいことだからやりますとか
聖書に書いているんだからやりますとか
経典にあるんだからやりますとかね
そういうのはあんまり本物にならないんですね
言われたんだからやりますと
奥さんにもうきつくもう怒られるんだから
じゃあやりますとかね
その場合は確実にストレスだ
言われたんだからやるんでもなくて
自分が褒めてくれるんだからやるんでもなくて
ただするだけと こういうこういうことする
それだけと 自分が自分の行為の結果として
みんないろいろ大変幸福になったら別にそれはもうどうでも関係ないんだと
そういうことで行動的になると
仏教ではそれにプラスアルファに
だからといって何でも行動するっていうことはいけませんと
自分の行動は自分のためになるか
他人のためになるかと
両者のためになるかと
よく気をつけなさい だからエゴを捨てて友好的な行動をする
そうするともう善神なんですね
ですから この日常 24時間の中で寝ることさえもポジティブ的な感じで寝られますよ
今日 1 日はよく頑張ったと
じゃあ寝ようではないかと
ああ よかったと という感じで
寝ること自体もこのもう不善神ではなくて
善神で寝られますよ 人間というのはかわいそうに
寝る時は不善神で 起きる時は不善神で
料理作る時は不善神で
食べる時はまた不善神で
仕事をする時は不善神で
もう何へとその善神が分かっている
それで もうストレス溜まってるんだとか
あ 困ったとか悩んだとか
どうしようどうしようと
心配だとか恐怖感とか
自信がないとか そればっかりなんです
本当はばかばかしい 自信がないと
ないけどね 何に自信持ってほしいんですかね
何のための自信が必要ですかね
元気で確実にいればいいのに
これ自信とは関係ないものでしょ
自分知ったことがないんだと思えばそれだけのことですから
別に自分の仕事をされすればいいし
これには自信がない それエゴから出てくるんですよ
ピッタにしていい顔をいい
もう何て言いますか 顔をしたいんだと
褒めてもらいたいんだ
それはエゴだから そこで自信がないということは出てくるんですね
ですからまあ大体人間というのは人の前でしゃべるのはすごい苦手ですけどね
別にしゃべるのはあんまりいいことじゃないんだけどね
しゃべること自体は避けた方が一番いいことなんですけどね
まあどうしてもこの場ではもう自分しかない
じゃあ私しかないか じゃあしゃべります
それだけのことを しゃべればそのものは済みますし
私がしゃべらなくたっていいや
この場合はこの人としゃべれば
それだってその人に分かってよ
それじゃなんでその人としゃべるんだ
私にもできるのではないかとか
それでまた私 いろいろ混乱生まれるでしょうね
じゃああなたにお願いしますって言ったところで
あ これすごいかっこつけて喋らなくちゃいけない
それでいろいろ準備したり言われたところでも
もう大外れとかね 全くウケなかったとか
そういうこともありますから
で またすごい自己嫌悪になったりとか
めちゃくちゃなんだ生き方って
だから善心処の方を発見すると
全部消えて素晴らしい幸福の生き方が現れてくる
それはまた善行為だから
幸福から幸福へ行ってしまうんです
じゃあとにかくそういうことで
この十九種類のあの興
定 信 処はどんな明るいところが確実にあることで
あの区別はできないんですね
次に出てくるのは うんと
まず助け それからこの三つのヴィラティ
ヴィラティという体質が三つ出てくるんですね
それはサンマー サンマーワーチャ
サンマカンマンタ サンマーワーチャ
サンマカンマンタ サンマーアージーヴァ
それはヴィラティ三つと言うんですね
いろんな名前でカテゴライズしていますけど
それはこの勉強しやすくするために
ただ難しいするためではなくて
このそういういろんなカテゴリーにっていうのは名前は必要なんですけど
で サンマーワーチャは正語
これは正語 これは正命
で 正しい言葉を喋ることと
正しい行為をすることと
正しい仕事を探すことなんですね
で そこでなぜヴィラティっていうのは何か避けるという意味なんですね
何を避けるかというと
悪いことを避けるという意味でヴィラティと言うんです
言葉は喋るんだけど 悪い言葉を喋らないように気をつけること
いろんな行動はするんだけど
悪い行動をしないように気をつけること
仕事はするんだけど 悪いことをして金もうけませんと
自分の生き方を気をつける
ですから戒律なんですね
わかりやすく言うと そういうことでヴィラティと言われる
その三つは出世間心に瞑想して覚る心には必ずしも生まれるんです
必ずしも一緒に生まれるのです
で 他の善心の場合はまあ適当に生まれるんだそうです
別々別に 一緒には生まれません
例えばいい言葉を喋ると
悪い言葉から離れましょうと思ったら
言葉心が言葉の中心に入りますから
サンマーワーチャが生まれる
行為を自分の行動をコントロールするときはサンマカンマンタが生まれる
自分の命のことを考えちゃうと
いわゆる食べることを生きることを考えちゃうと
悪いことをしてはいけませんと
生きるために食べるためにと思っちゃうとサンマーアージーヴァが生まれる
ですからバラバラに生まれるんですね
その時その時だけ いつでも善心処
善心だからこれあるわけじゃないんです
善心っていうのは明るい元気な心
それは善心 これプラスアルファでサンマーワーチャになる
サンマーカンマンタになる
サンマーアージーヴァになるということは
まあプラスアルファのことなんです
そこで善心処と善心と言っても
あのサマーディ心には生まれません
いわゆる色 色界心と無色界心には生まれないんですね
それはただの瞑想だけして生まれる心だから
色界と無色界の心はたくさんありますね
十五プラスと十二  二十七あります
で その時はこの戒律のことはまあ関係ないんです
関係ないけど 戒律はある人が瞑想するんだからね
それは基本的な条件で瞑想というその行為には戒律ということは関係なくなっちゃうんです
もう何もしないことだからね
戒律の場合